I remember you in your heyday could you
bring it with this avenges leave the
chandeliers big fella
boy that is strong can you relate RJ
Barrett cross screen and attack and
drive Barrett so good at getting to the
basket showing some emotion right there
visibility around the basket Shaquille
back in the day just watch out here
little Showtime right now I love this
play right here bear it gets out look at
the who's celebrating his play
Zions trailing and look at that it's
pretty explosive right there himself now
- watch your head
- 396 playful Louie a great finisher
around the basket RJ Barrett's has been
so consistent act towards is really got
to going on one little step back and
Barrett get the puppies organized
drilling it here they are with the first
ever in C tournament win as a Friday
night
in the patch and it drops rezaian would
agree pass tomba by orj parrot finding
zion williamson lance and again how you
able to jump everybody chimp trailing
[Music]
in a rush city level and get out of the
open court in rj barrett so good at
attacking the rim avoiding the charge
right there a tremendous touch on that
shot that's not an easy shot right there
but Duke they just human beings on the
planet of seven six always player in
common basketball or the NBA and they
score right over
taco Falls Dukes first point to the
second half a free throw to tie it 5 out
of 6 at the line
Vista comes up short two seconds as
let's set up now as you see again the
putback off the missed free throw for
the lead now it's what happens when you
could shoot from deep Zion now we'll try
the three
looking around saying I don't like this
guy inside around this time they came
back from a deficit was 2001 against
Maryland at the Final Four in
Minneapolis I love this and look at this
stark man they come right out with a
play and finally break that field goal
drought with Barrett he said it best
that's a nice little screen enrolled and
ours a didn't settle he attacked the TT
terrific re gives it to the Lane knows
he's got some contact finish to deal
with a chance for another a little life
and there's his was somebody first
turnover in 13 minutes did she do for
the lead back and 5150 but this they
dead astern this third foul pretty
impressive right here this again put it
on verse 5 for Michigan State now it's a
call the floor I love that a little play
with thee Carl's he's so good at that
and how do you get around if you tag
with Williams to be the bump you see em
and Virginia Tech nice job coins on that
Duncan hairs Barrett his pit play was
they've paid attention to the amazing
guy on the side
Darrin looking for a little opening and
he finds it he knows how to do Li
quality search hang a little and the
kiss